hello linkedin
linkedin live i haven't done these for a
few weeks i think gabby it's your first
one right
it is my first ever linkedin live let's
hope people turn up
i know we're just talking about
hopefully yeah
at least one of your colleagues will
hopefully turn up and and show up which
would be nice
um but as we were just saying so
what we're gonna do in the next sort of
30 35 minutes that uh we're going to be
on this
linkedin live is um
get your questions answered so for those
of you that may or may not have seen or
listened yet
um i released an episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast with gabby
and we uncovered her recruitment journey
from being a 19 year old to join the
industry to now managing leading her own
team
um so we are gonna talk a bit about
um the podcast and what we discussed but
where we thought we would start is uh
just talking about
um yeah how how gabby's feeling about um
with the announcement on the weekend and
what
you've been communicating to your team
how you're thinking about the next
couple of weeks
um and then hopefully we'll get some
questions from you lovely people that
are joining us so um before i get gabby
to introduce herself
um if you are joining us let us know um
in the comments let us know
where you're joining us from today and
uh how you're feeling
about the full week lockdown
i know but um gabby let tell us a bit
about
who you are and what you do and uh we'll
go from there
okay brilliant so i'm gabby trotter
hopefully you've listened to the podcast
but if not
um i've been in recruitment for it's
just gone five years now and i recruit
in the tech space so specifically
software testing roles across the north
west and
yorkshire and i have a small team sat
alongside me
as well kind of covering the other
locations throughout the uk
yeah awesome um so let's start
where was you when you uh heard the news
about the lockdown on the weekend kind
of maybe ironically but i was out for
food
um because he kept us waiting so kindly
for so long it was literally like right
we'll watch it before we go we'll watch
it in the car we'll watch it before we
go in and it just got to the point where
we were just sat at the table both on
our phones like this at the meal
you know took took a little bit of the
edge off a wonderful
saturday evening but there we go um i
actually do remember kind of looking
around me as well and thinking
i know this is rubbish but how rubbish
is it for
everyone that actually works in this
restaurant right now yeah yeah
myself lucky that i'm still going to
continue going to work so
kind of put it in a bit of context for
me but not
yeah i think yeah perspective like that
helps a lot doesn't it
because you can get caught up in your
own head and think your world's over and
there's always some good places you can
go but so how
what so let's start with like what what
have you been communicating so how big
is your team again
at the moment okay so what what have you
what have you communicated to your team
so i think and it's all that you can do
is just
keeping positive obviously you know
we're facing the reality of it it is
very much
um we're going to be back to that kind
of completely
work from home model and that's going to
be an adjustment but i really do feel
hopeful
given the sector that we work in and the
fact that we've been through this once
and everyone's
moved to the remote working model and
video interviews
i'm really hoping and touch wood that
this time it's not going to be such a
big shock and we're not going to see
a big impact so just kind of pushing on
really and just trying to keep things
moving forward as much as we can okay
awesome fair enough
um so obviously you guys are you going
straight are you
working from home from yes so i'm in the
office today we're just kind of
figuring things back out and we just a
lot more prepared than last time in
terms of the equipment we can send
people home with
and just making sure that it's as easy
as possible but kind of as of tomorrow
onwards
completely back working from home for
the full month because you know it's the
right thing to do
for everyone involved so um
let me ask you this then so like with
that in mind like what
what do you see being a potential
biggest challenge from a recruitment
perspective over the next four weeks so
you're pushing on romanian positive
like what what do you anticipate as the
potential
sort of challenge that you might have to
deal with over the next couple of weeks
i think the challenge is going to lie
more within
kind of myself and the team than than
the clients and the candidates as i say
i think it's just going to be
getting used to to kind of i suppose
being alone again and not having the
other people to bounce off
um i think that that's always a
difficult adjustment
um to kind of go from that buzzing kind
of sales environment that the
recruitment
is into kind of sitting into a room by
yourself so i think
that that's going to be the biggest
adjustment as i say i'm really hopeful
that it's
not going to have too much of a knock-on
effect around kind of interviews and
everything like that because we've kind
of already dealt with all these barriers
kind of six months ago
so i hope that that's not going to kind
of crop back up again as an excuse for
for things to be kind of pulled or
cancelled
okay so how so i don't know because i've
spoke to
a couple of people um yesterday and
today where they had new starters
this week and they're all starting fine
it's all good
like how how have the conversations been
with clients and candidates then has it
been the
right we're carrying on we're all going
remote in the middle or end of the week
like how how they reacted in your market
yeah so i would say already kind of
85 to 90 were already working from home
and never kind of made that return back
so they're obviously
set there's a couple that have been back
in the office
so they're obviously going to take some
time to kind of readjust to the remote
working model it depends
it's so much um variation depending on
the sectors that these people work
within and kind of the setups that they
have um we've seen a couple of start
dates getting pushed back
because they'd rather actually be able
to induct them in person in december so
whether we'll see a bit more of that
you know hopefully not but these are
little things that might
might crop up for us you know things
being pushed into december
so so that kind of takes the uncertainty
out of it
yeah sure okay interesting um
so back to sort of interesting that you
said around the potential challenges
could actually be more internal
in terms of your team and things like
that and i'm sure a lot of people are
feeling the same way
so i guess what did you learn from
the previous lockdown and the challenges
that we've sort of been going through
over the last
six or so months that sort of you're
going to really try and focus on
and will help you support your team
help them otherwise stay productive or
help them manage
um with this challenge mentally like
what what are you going to
sort of make sure you do for your team
or try and implement with your team that
can make sure that morale stays up and
um yeah they're they're working um as
well as they can and enjoying it
yeah so definitely frequent check-ins
and just making sure that the
communication doesn't drop off the face
of a cliff and you know we're all
keeping in touch
um something that worked really well
previously and it doesn't always go to
plan because obviously you know your day
can sometimes change massively in this
job you know you can't always plan what
you're going to do but what we have done
previously while working from home is
kind of almost having like a group
bd morning or a group bb session
throwing in kind of little wins into
teams and you know what's working for
you what's not working for me and i
think
that gives you that sense of team even
though you're all in split different
locations and it just helps to kind of
keep morale up so that was really fun
last time so we'll definitely
push on with that because i think it
does help when you've got so you had
sort of
yeah sort of great so you had sort of
group activities and you all knew that
you're
doing the similar things at the same
time and then so
and then this com this came out of a
previous podcast but like how
how important is it then to have a bit
of a debrief after those sessions like
would you
always typically like have a bit of a so
right right guys we're all in in this
together we're doing this over the next
couple of hours and then would you
always make sure that
you're booking a bit of like okay well
what do people achieve what do you do
do you typically book in a debrief and
has that helped
yeah definitely i think when you work
from home it's really easy to
constantly communicate with each other
when things are going well but it's
really easy to
to keep things to yourself and hide away
from it when things are going badly
you know so i just want to obviously
make clear to the team that
don't just come to me with good news
come to me with the bad come to me if
you're struggling and just making sure
that you know people aren't
sitting there alone kind of letting
things run away with them
yeah yeah sure interesting okay so
for anyone that's um joined us please do
uh we're gonna chat for another uh
15 uh 20 minutes so um do let us know if
you have any questions
um and we'll get those answered um
but look i think um one of the things
that i really took from
um our podcast and gabby was
sort of how you've had to get better at
um really understanding what motivates
your team
so it's about back to this point um and
i guess
maybe final point unless we get some
questions like how are you gonna
encourage or touch on people's drivers
remotely does that change at all i don't
know
like does that become more difficult
like how how are you gonna make sure
that
yeah you encourage people's drivers when
you're all sitting
at home yeah i think it does become more
difficult because i think
everything almost switches and again i'm
saying that i'm hopeful that it's
nowhere near as extreme as last time but
you almost switch
from normal day-to-day life and what
you're working towards to almost a
little bit more of kind of a
fight-or-flight mode where
it's just very much you know oh we just
want we just want to get through this
month
you know obviously we want the villains
to remain and we want to do well but
it almost kind of fades into the
background a little bit more and people
are just conscious of like let's just
get through this month so
i think it's just making sure that
people refer back to the long term goals
and realize yeah it might be a tougher
month but we're working towards a bigger
picture here and your bigger goals and
your bigger targets and
let's not just write those up you know
let's get let's keep really focused on
those and help them to drive us through
okay interesting and um
i think a big challenge is is obviously
what people can have to go through
mentally
with this right because i think um
i don't know i just think it's i mean
yeah as we said earlier like there's
going to be a lot of people that are
going to be in tougher situations but
i think a lot of people might feel like
they were just starting to build up some
momentum and then
sort of like oh god say right i've got
adapt back to this now right so i guess
um what what are you going to do
yourself
to sort of give yourself the best
possible chance of
having more good days than potential bad
days mentally i mean for me
the things that really helped me were
making sure that um
i left the house left the flat and
actually went for a walk even if that's
like a 15
20 minute walk um because you can that
you can always find
things to do and and work to do um
for me it was yeah and then part of that
is like trying to try and exercise as
much as possible
and if that's if that's um obviously
you're just running but don't be too
hard on yourself if you missed a couple
of days
um and then for me um i don't know what
what your experience was like but uh
during the last lockdown
like a casual beer with dinner always
quite easy turns like two three
four beers within that oh yeah i'm
strongly relate
um from that one yes so i guess for me
i'm just gonna
try and make sure that i have a morning
routine
that sort of gives me the best chance of
having a better day
uh go for as many walks as possible um
and
try not drink as much um what are you
gonna what are you gonna try and do that
hopefully
will help you have better days than
bad days yeah i think the exercise one
and the game for walk one is great and
obviously
you know we're in a tough time a year it
was all fun and games and summer
finishing work and it was a light
evening and going for a wander
not so fun in the um and pitch black
dark
but it's going to be that extra push to
just get yourself to leave the house 100
i think that's going to be so important
um for me as well
i think actually just getting ready for
the day and
as you would if you were coming to a
workplace and you know not just sitting
there in
in pajamas or whatever it would be
because i think that does help your
mindset a lot
and so just just approaching every day
as as you would normally i know it's not
normal but just trying to
to kind of keep that routine as much as
possible
sure so yeah so i think having a bit of
a i think it's like having a bit of a
routine but have making sure that you're
trying to
build a routine that like serves you as
well do you know what i mean and
recognize the
oh actually yeah when i do wake up and
go on my phone straight away that
doesn't really make my day start very
well or whatever do you know what i mean
like actually like thinking about right
what
what what routine can really help me
have have a good day
and that's awesome love that so like how
i think on this point i think what what
can what i've heard quite a few times
and what can be quite difficult as a
manager of a team
is like picking up on those queues or
picking up on
when people might be struggling do you
know what i mean
so because it can be quite hard can't it
to sort of really read body language for
a screen or
it might it could be easier for your
guys to be like no i am okay when really
they're not
do you know what i mean because there's
a screen between us and we're not
we can't sort of sense that sort of
energy when we're face to face sitting
next to each other
so i guess what what are you what how do
you approach
like just really trying to make sure
that you're checking in with the guys
and
making sure they're okay and stuff like
that what what worked for you previously
yeah it's so hard isn't it it's that
transition because we're so funny my
team
you know we we know each other and we
read each other so well like if someone
comes in and they sit down
in the first thing you kind of know okay
let's give them
a coffee because they're obviously not
feeling it as much today but
you know over teams you can't get that
same breed so i think
i think it's just you know pestering
really and just making sure that
it's constant communication and constant
checking in and
just making sure that you're asking the
right questions that you can get to kind
of
an issue quickly if needs be yeah and i
think
i think this came from your podcast
right and i think part of that is like
yeah that doesn't mean that you're
always calling them and asking them
about
recruitment right like also checking in
like yeah
asking about life and and what's going
on
right of course definitely and i think
you know one of the guys on my team he
does live alone so
i know that it's going to be difficult
for him because he's not got
that family there or that partner there
so i'm you know i'm already
thinking about that in advance and i
know it is going to be a tough time for
him so just making sure that
we're checking in on people because
there'll be a lot of people in that same
situation
yeah that's awesome so um i guess
um another thing on this which i think
will be interesting for for people that
are with us and might be managers i
guess how
are you i guess you'll see how it goes
but
like what's your thought process on
certain um activities that you want to
be looking at right now
in terms of like measuring performance
stuff like that you know what i mean
because i know last time um when we
recorded the podcast i know it's
different now but
you said that you went back to basics
and you really focus on small wins
seems like hopefully obviously a lot of
your clients have sort of in a position
now where they can
push forward and and this wouldn't
affect him too much but how are you
thinking in terms of
activities and and sort of what you keep
what you think you're going to keep in
mind in terms of performance wise of the
team and stuff like that
definitely yeah so obviously keeping an
eye on metrics and kind of kpis is going
to be really important
and and we're staying hopeful so as long
as we are seeing that those cv cents are
turning into interviews then you know
everything's going as we're planning
if we're starting to see that dropping
off and we're realizing that the people
that we're already working with are
perhaps slowing things down or they're
going to put things on hold
we need to identify that early and kind
of flip the switch into a very kind of
business development focused place so
i think we're going to take this week to
kind of read the market read what's
going on and then kind of make a plan of
action from there
um that makes sense exactly where we're
up to i suppose and how and what
and what what does that consist of how
are you approaching is it as simple as
right right guys like we over the next
week the sort of task is right we need
to check in with
all of our clients the clients that we
have requirements with who are hiring
and and then really start to build a
picture and then use all that context
then as what the plan is
100 yeah so just not burying your head
in the sand at all
we'd rather know now if someone is
pushing that role back or that role's
being pulled whatever it might be
best to know asap and then you can kind
of factor that into your month and go
from there so just asking those leading
questions getting a good
a good read of exactly where you're up
to and i think is going to be really
important over the next few days for
everyone whatever sector they're in
yeah sure and so if i if i i think
that's a great exercise right
like if you're if you're joining us and
and you're not approaching at this this
week that's probably something that
maybe you should think about
as you said i think the idea and what
you want to do is be in the position of
the
um be in the know if if people are going
to start saying well actually let's just
hold off on
hiring this person or we're going to
push the start dates back to december
maybe in the new year
um so you really want to be in the know
right so
i guess what i think might be valuable
uh for people
um is like if i do have those
conversations this week
and it really turns out that actually
yeah people are going to wait
till december or actually that's
actually quite close to christmas so
actually what we'll do
we'll wait we'll start people in the
year right that could happen right
so if i'm then like right wow okay i
need to i need to then have a bit of a
business development person and make
sure i'm doing that
how how are you how do you think you're
going to then be approaching that
with what like over the next four weeks
you know i mean because i think that was
one of the biggest challenges for
and still maybe the biggest challenge in
terms of clients and business
development and
and winning uh business like how how
how are you going to be approaching
business development if it does turn out
that
quite a few people actually aren't
hiring as you anticipated you need to
back
get back and making sure that um you've
got plenty of opportunities
yeah no definitely i think it's pretty
much the same as what you're saying on
the client side so
knowledge is power so it's just knowing
if okay so if these people i'm working
with
aren't pushing forward how do i find out
who is and i think the way to do that is
going to be to tap into your network
and to tap into candidates that are out
there you know on the call face
looking for jobs and and finding out
information from them
who is still pushing on with the
recruitment and where where should i be
channeling my energy towards
they're they're going to be the ones in
the know right now so
just happening into that network really
yeah awesome love that
so um look we're we're gonna try and get
some questions gabby if you've got any
colleagues you can drop a message
getting to ask some some questions to
help it out
but no we're going to chat with the song
there we go that's so much better but
we're going to um chat for another 10
minutes and then we'll
we'll finish this but i guess so we've
spoken a lot about clients spoken about
what we're going to approach there what
what you fi so what i've been hearing a
lot gabby interested to get your
thoughts on this and this might
resonate with people is like surely
like the confidence of a candidate
moving in this market has probably
been even more damaged right in terms of
what going on so
i guess i'm sure that's um i'm assuming
here but like is
a common challenge you're hearing maybe
from for yourself or for your guys that
um look people are really worried about
moving
in this market so i guess how have you
been how have you been dealing with that
if the candidates
and candidates in your market have been
sort of telling you and your team that
that they're really
they're really not confident to move
what
what have you been talking what have you
been communicating and how you've been
overcoming that
so a lot of it is just it's very much
kind of there
i don't want to say hand-holding but
almost hand-holding people through the
process obviously it's a super sensitive
time it's a tricky time to move roles
totally different if you've obviously
been let go or you're on furlough and
you move in for security but if you're
in a secure role
it seems like a very bold move to be
moving to another role right now
um but just tapping into you know what
was the reason in the first place that
we spoke what was the reason you applied
or the reason that you you took the
phone call from me
you're after something more um and this
role is providing that
there's always an element of a leap of
faith but sometimes you have to kind of
make these big decisions in life to get
the big payout
so it's just guiding people through the
process and you know not applying too
much pressure and knowing when to step
away when it's just simply
you know not the right thing for them or
for your client
yeah yeah sure and then like is it is
that something that you're then
communicating back to clients that look
we are going to the market we're
speaking to people and people really are
worried about moving like i don't know
is it
i don't know have you sort of had those
conversations with clients and they've
sort of helped um communicate to you why
how serious they are about hiring and it
isn't going to be
first in first out do you know what i
mean like what what
what have you been collaborating with
clients and sort of trying to
communicate this as well and how they
how they've been handling that or what
do they think about your clients
definitely and that's like a number one
kind of key
new question that we're asking at any
point of taking down a new role or
taking down a new spec
is obviously what's the reason for the
vacancy but
how have you fared throughout this
period have you got people on furlough
at the moment have you had to make
anyone redundant and
we're not necessarily going to say
anything negative
whatever the answer is but it's being
armed with the information and
just trying to find out um exactly what
we can i suppose
feedback to the candidates to make sure
that they know that this is a safe move
so if it's an e-commerce client you know
if sales are up a certain amount then
brilliant note that down and that's like
a key number of information that's going
to
help people make make a more informed
decision
yes it's really tapping into that
consultative piece isn't it and
like really digging into like why are
they hiring this person
and yeah context like that like well
actually we've increased 500 percent in
sales and
that's why we need this person that
hopefully can just give you an even
better chance of instilling
confidence um in people
um so i guess um with that
um as well then like do you
i've seen this quite quite a lot but
obviously there's gonna be candidates
there's gonna be a lot of struggles for
for candidates right um in this market
obviously
some people might be put back on
furlough or still be on furlough
um but how
what advice have you been candid to give
being given candidates to sort of um
help themselves get opportunities right
i think um oh actually i've got a
question from your colleague let's
let's get out of here yeah it's pretty
much where i was going christopher what
advice would you give to candidates that
are looking for
new roles on how to make themselves
stand out from others right that was
sort of where i was going because i'm
sure you might be getting that a lot
um and this might mean that it may not
involve a recruiter
right but like i don't know what i'm
sure you're getting this a lot so i
guess what have you been sort of
communicating to your network on
sort of um what can help candidates
actually break through the noise and
have a chance in um getting back into
employment or progress in their career
yeah no definitely so number one i think
working with the recruiter and the right
recruiter is definitely you know a top
tip and it's definitely worthwhile
i think as well i think
quality over quantity in terms of the
applications that you're making
because there's so many applications and
we find it when we're posting jobs at
the moment
i know that obviously if you're looking
for something new what you want to do is
you know blanket approach almost but i
think you get so much more back
when you actually probably tailor your
application
entail your email and cover letter or
whatever it is to that specific role
even if you only end up applying for
half the amount i truly do think that
will make a big difference in actually
seeing
um a response kind of increase because i
think
that there's so many applications at the
moment there's so many candidates that
it's not enough to just kind of be good
and have a good cv you need you know a
great cv and you need to stand out
yeah so are you are you finding then
because it are interesting actually and
thank you chris for that
question um so i i've had quite a few
conversations and they're
they're in different different
industries a couple of recruiters that
um are in the design space ux ui
and the copy tech recruiters as well
yeah so
the context that i've got is that
actually over the last little couple of
weeks they've actually noticed a real
drop off in applications
have you not have you not experienced
that like they've put out quite a few
vacancies over the last couple of weeks
and actually
compared to where it was like three four
five months ago
yeah like they're getting a certain
they're getting a significant
less amount of applications i suppose
it's difficult for what i do because
testing
pre-pandemic during pandemic after
pandemic whatever
you're always just going to get a lot of
applications that is just
the market's always been the same since
i started working the market so
i wouldn't say that i have seen a drop
off of anything you know
there was a role that we posted the
other day and i think overnight we had
like
150 applications for that one role
and i don't think that you know
obviously there were some people that
were completely unsuitable but you know
there was
a big big amount of genuinely suitable
people it's just you know it's how it's
so difficult then to filter that down
to a short list as i say you know if
someone's got the edge by this much by
what they've written on their cv or
their telecover letter you know they're
going to get your slot so
it's so competitive so so on that
and i think this is a real common
challenge as well and let me know if
sort of you and all your your guys have
been dealing with this is
so what you just said there right in
terms of you posted a position
you got yeah x amount of applications
and actually there was a good chunk of
people that
um actually fit the mark right
potentially what how do you deal with
the objection of well gabby look why
would we pay you a fee if we can do that
like we can put up a job and get x
amount of people do all that you know
what i mean
because i'm sure that's i'm sure that's
an injection well
yeah how have you been overcoming that
and have you been communicating to
clients as to well actually this is the
value that
we can bring and it's not as easy as
putting a job at getting all these
applications and filling the job
definitely well number one it's so time
consuming to thoroughly
and properly go through all the
applications to start with
so you know i it's my job to do that so
that's fine i can spend my day doing
that
if you're the test manager or the cto
i'm sure you've got
plenty of other things that you need to
be doing and you know it's just not
viable to feed through that many
applications um
and as well you know although there'll
be there'll be great applications in
that a lot of the placements that we do
is from more so referrals or you know
head hunting people directly so
you know you're not always going to get
the best person by just putting an
advert out and i suppose that's what
we're saying you know put your own
advert out if you like but then let me
provide
who i can find best out of my network
and we'll see we'll see who's best
that's kind of my go-to line we'll see
okay fair enough um so just got a
question from um
max let me put it on the screen and
let's end it here and then um look if
anyone
wants to ask gabby anything further drop
her a connection i'm sure she'd be happy
to help
so this is an interesting one okay
how does gabriel go about business
development when hiring managers are
working from home and you can't actually
get hold of them by calling the company
um yeah i don't know i'm assuming then
yeah if you can't get through
typical switchboards or i don't know i
guess you want to try and get their
mobile number but
what yeah um number one scour the
internet for the mobile number
and then i think i think just just
embracing the fact that most people
are not going to be as accessible on the
phone at the moment so you really need
to step up your game in terms of the
content that you sounding out there
via emails and the content that you're
putting out across kind of social media
and linkedin
to catch people's eye so i think just
adapting and evolving
your approach um and i i would always
say as well you know feel free to reach
out to people
on different platforms that you wouldn't
normally think to do so whether that's
um away from linkedin and on a twitter
account or
wherever you can find these people
within reason you know let's not harass
people but
let's be a little bit more inventive
with it and you know you can always fall
back on that
the excuse that well i couldn't get you
on the phone so i sent you a dm
did you actually think that people were
less contactable then
um i i've definitely seen that obviously
you know there's been an increase in
in trying to get hold of people through
normal means and obviously
just kind of you know my phone lines
literally ringing out at officers not
even kind of a voicemail so i i think
that it has definitely gotten more
difficult
but i'd say my approach has always been
not necessarily reliant on the phone
anyway so i've not seen a massive change
but i can see
if you're that person that loves getting
on the phone to people how it could be
quite a tough time
yeah i guess it's that idea isn't it
that initially yeah you
may think you have loads of time but and
then you wake up and realize that you've
got
30 back-to-back zoom video calls put in
your diary
did you know i mean so like yeah i get
as to why that could be
a bit more uh difficult but um look
that's 30 minutes in there it went
really well
um look thank you so much for doing this
i really appreciate it and
thanks for for those of you that that
joined um
as i said if you want to uh learn more
about sort of gabby's journey and and so
what she's learned along the way in her
sort of recruitment career
make sure you check out our episodes and
and yeah
drop grab your connection if you want to
ask anything and you think she may be
able to help i'm sure she'll be happy to
help
and um hopefully we can all get through
this together right just let's just try
and
try and do yeah just i guess for me i'm
just thinking about right what can i do
today that hopefully can help me have a
a good day and and continue to try and
do that rather than focusing on all the
things that
i can't control on those things right um
but gabby thank you so much
absolute pleasure no problem thank you